i i've done obviously it's wrong
it comes down to like your safety as
well yeah of course but that's i think
it's a bit different in that situation i
gotta say
when when you're seeing it happen yeah
that this is as well
the judgment call comes in a little
different to what like in reality about
what we might places are actually for
this man to protect i think like the
first thing
that's just gonna say yeah
that's why i think girls get away with a
lot of stuff too is they know that they
know if they act a certain way in public
men will come to their rescue
because
you see them in court crying and stuff
because like our default is like oh
protect she's crying she's hurt you know
how many times you see the video girl
doing something to a guy and then her
boyfriend having to bear the
repercussions of her doing that thing to
the guy so yeah you know a woman
starting on the man and then that man
punching her boyfriend up
i think that's starting to reverse
though now i i've experienced it
personally
um i used to open the door for every
woman
young or old
and uh so many times have i had to say
thank you for them
and i'll say it loud okay oh you're
welcome
you know and and what i'm walking away
thinking is like you know what that's
the last time i ever opened a door for a
woman seriously i didn't think and and
i've i i'm ashamed to say that i saw it
because it changed me
in the negative i think that's something
nice to do for everyone i was taught
that that's what you do for a woman i
believe that's wrong no i think that's
something you do for everyone
but i see that the chivalry that a lot
of women like to see in guys
is kind of disappearing
i think it should and because we don't
appreciate you know whether it's sure it
shouldn't i think we're in a state where
one group of us wants it the other group
of us wants to do it but doesn't see the
point and actually gets a lot of crap
you know what i've noticed so we're just
kind of like at this point we're like
you know i would rather just
you do you even if you're in the corner
and you're getting hurt i'm going to go
over here because i'm not interested in
the consequences of that you know what
i've noticed is that when women say
they're romantic they mean they want the
man to be romantic romantic it's not
themselves like they would never buy
flowers they want the guy to buy flowers
for them
that's what romance is to them
can i ask something that's true i'm
interested that's very that's like
at least of of modern women it's maybe
the older generations women used to do
things for the guys in other ways but i
think yeah because then men were the
price though exactly oh i have a
question for the girls what's the most
romantic thing you've done for a guy
good one
um so i've done like um
a rooftop sort of picnic thing um for
my well then he was my boyfriend so
um went shopping got all the food he
liked to just
had that romantic setting for him and he
really appreciates it do you think
that's something that you would have
wanted or something he would have wanted
nice one
um
i'm just i don't know your man in it
is that something you would have wanted
or he would have wanted
or did he just appreciate it i think i
think he really liked it
he even called family and zoom cool and
it was like look what she did for me
but i guess what he's saying
from did you do for him what you wanted
him to do for you or did you actually
think like this is what that man
wants yeah do you think that men walk
around thinking oh you know what i
really want a romantic rooftop thing
yeah cause you would love that i would
love it but i know what you're talking
about we would probably like to watch
die hard by ourselves that would be
romantic for us
before you carry on
what you did
was wonderful no it was yeah we don't
want to take away from what you've done
we're just trying to yeah
yeah from the perspective of a man like
if i
for example i i just came back from
scotland i had a beautiful visit with a
woman that i adore
she's if i was to marry a woman this
would be exactly the type and she's old
school she takes care of her man
and one of the things that she did for
me when i arrived
is she she had a suit waiting for me
and she put that suit on me
she made me dinner that
night we went out we went to a jazz club
over in scotland i went up on stage she
sat there and chilled and waited for me
and when i was done and everybody was
done talking to me she just sat there
and she waited for me
that was what women would consider
romantic from a guy's perspective i
don't think that's really romantic from
a woman's perspective but if you want my
heart
that's that's how you get it because she
did everything that i just wish every
woman would do for me i see your point i
think maybe if the question was asked to
my fiance maybe he might come up with a
different example of something else i've
done but because the question was locks
to me
i would say that's probably the most
romantic thing so i'm gonna frame it i
can't frame it as a man i would love if
someone did that for me oh my god but in
general men are romantic for themselves
i mean it's different what about you
jess
my mind's just blown right now because
um what i did i would say probably one
of the
most romantic things was similar to you
but it was for his birthday i like
balloons happy birthday and it was a
surprise he didn't know that it was
happening got him some of his favorite
stuff
um
bought some things that he needed and
just like a little goodie bag and then i
surprised him confetti everything
balloons the whole nine
and from hearing what you guys are
saying
that's something that i would want
someone to do for me like surprisingly
like hey babe like your birthday the
senator and i'm like no no it's not like
that but
what
like to understand like how men think
what is like
something that
so say for your birthday what is
something that you would want a woman to
do for you that is romantic and immansen
and manson not in a woman's
for me personally for me personally all
i need for my goal is to you know
put on some animes that i watch and
order some pizza and we watch it
together and i'll be calm that's all i
thought
like i would have needed much more than
that buy me ps5 if you want what would
be what what would be above and beyond
so buying you a ps5 you're buying buy me
a ps5 taking me abroad like anything
like that oh you want to be you want to
be taken on youtube
you want to be fluent out you wanna
where
where do you want her to take you like
maybe there could be some girls in the
chat watching a married man
without a ring look at it look at it fly
him out
what i'm saying is it's like it's the
little things you know if you're showing
interest in the things that i have
interest in then that's that's all i
need like i wouldn't need anything extra
to me the best thing is like where they
listen to you say you said something at
some point i really want to read this
book whatever because that's what my ex
did she was in sweden i was in australia
i told her once ages ago i really want
to read this book sapiens i don't know
if you read it great book
i wake up one day i have a delivery it's
that book why should you extend it
yesterday
no that because when i was when i was
with my ex-boyfriend i bought him like a
phone wall at once and it was just
because he like mentioned he like needed
it but it was i didn't understand why i
was such a big he was like
that was so nice
and i was like it's just a lot like it
was like five bucks i just saw it at the
store
yeah you remember it
yeah
women like the gesture
you know they like to go window shopping
because they like the act
men purchase things because of a need
that needs to be satisfied that's when
we go shopping we go on a mission to be
accomplished as quickly as possible
women like to extend the time as much as
possible because it's the act
that okay maybe you'll disagree this is
just my oh no for for me personally i
had to shop yes we were raised like boys
yes that's right
i'm a boy on the inside i was speaking
very i agree with you